あーわーおわー
[拍手]
花粉社員肇社長ですか分さあとこのはいいんだけどさ
僕たち人間に命をかけないでほしいねーまじふざけんなというわけでですね皆さん
ギリースーツで知っていますでしょうか
僕も昔同時に使ったことがあるんですけどでもサバゲーとかでコーンなら十分
妻とかせる時に行くさっきにがくれるために託児付緑僕でなくさときみたいな作る時で
こんもりとかに隠れてると相手からば入りたいのギリースーツっていうのがあるんです
けども
なーんとですよ奥さんとれのクールバージョンがあるみたいですっていう意味で買って
みましたあげてみましょう
をは前科ああ
やばーフェリーセンスが車ますね花木ラーズメットっていますえ待ってめっちゃでかい
んだけどって大きさなんかはからその後頬
うおうおおーヒューバーンってやばいで風邪ひいた理由わかっでええねん張って
ボデガス議員
混ぜそうだったけどこれじゃないませんだけある寺からちょっとあればいい
どうせに育てるぞえっ
まず出れないんですけど出れないしめちゃくちゃデカいのかやばい混ぜ込まれました
ちょっと子供は攻めさせていただきます今日の動画はなんか適当な理由をつけて山に
行きます車でターゲットを連れ連れて駅頭に中山に行きますね査定しまーす皆敵とな
こと言って車から降りて車が見えないところまで交通歩いた瞬間栗野町最後披露させて
希望された車にこれをつけてあげと帰ってきたら車がないけど実は近くなるんだけども
この gd 生徒を連れてくるなんで分かりづらいという
バレるとかバレないのが優勝していきたいとおもいますでは行こう
この国もうちょっと狼せるかどうか時いつもチェックしています
b
元ないでしょこれはう
だけど多分大丈夫だと思いますではターゲットを山に誘い込み車がなくなるときりやっ
ていこうと思います
でワイコン
あきっ
好きコメントありがとうございますレギュラー例えばというこっちゃ
か行かれた
の
畑の店かけたらメインチャンネルですではターゲット隠れちゃったんで
車もとデイズバレにくいところに隠します僕のイメージだとあそこなってね
もいいですね1回朝まで移動しません
どうすかいやもうめっちゃんこ見えますねあ作られたすぐバレるんですよ
めちゃんこ目立ちますねじゃあ多分バレないと思う結構遠くなんです
[音楽]
どうすかいやーけどわかりにくい底でちょっと離れて見てみます
ピント目が悪い人だとねこんな感じなんですよいやわぁ狩りづらいと思うぜこれ
入ってるけど多分かけてましたどうでしょうま近くで見ると笹にわかるんですけど遠く
から見るとさすがにカモフラージュてわからないと思うので果たしてこんなでかい車が
覚醒たらまずですごいと思うんですよ
車や技術は
有効なのかいう講座ないのか見ていこうと思いますでは
[音楽]
4そ
スパイだっはい
顔しちゃくちゃん
2分宮と汚れが言われ
が土が同校はそれゆけ
立っています
熱車ないでっ鍵誰か情報持ってないんだかじゃあ俺持って頭誰かに預けて右折
ブーバーへ
[音楽]
やばいじゃんいっ
ズって界のこれ
同社もしれん
追って塩ベルト限ると言う夫がないよ絶対絶対エンディングブリ彼が朝止めたら大地
くん積んだよこれが辛がってた雪8番2に山でとあるでもそれほどんだか
ハーイ嘘ちょっとエビてくる
[拍手]
ん
現在はございません
寝られずっといっ神ば鍵は誰か誰か
あ食べたからねえ
一つできてない戻ってきてないですよ
[音楽]
えーどういった著
そういう地域これは割り出し幅ガッツで目立って呪いじゃバイポットないんだねっ
残っという言葉言ってたもんね
思います
ですでしょえっ masa ですよね
地名一つかですあれや2積み技ということですね
うちの車やこれはっはーんちゅるぱやなんか
なんかすごい気にされている
というわけで車がなくなるードッキリでしたーー
ええええええ
誰
[音楽]
me
ええええええ
えっあっ
前週はないあ知ってたまた俺また俺
なぁ肌がまだらだあ高められる
ああああねええええ